[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et cette semaine notre invité
Thomas ménager bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député rassemblement national du Loiret
depuis 2022 nouveau député on va revoir
avec vous le film de la semaine et on
fera le bilan de l'action de l'Assemblée
nationale un an après les élections
législatives qui n'avaient donné qu'une
majorité relative à Emmanuel Macron on
verra quelles sont les textes qu'il
reste à défendre pour le gouvernement
dans les prochaines semaines
la dissolution du mouvement écologiste
les soulèvements de la Terre a été
prononcé mercredi en Conseil des
ministres Gérald de Darmanin a dénoncé
violences de ses militants mais cette
dissolution divise les parlementaires le
Sénat adopter cette semaine le projet de
loi industriaire d'un texte qui favorise
les filières industrielles de la
transition écologique l'enjeu est de
concilier réindustrialisation et
préservation de l'environnement
il y a un dans les Français Élisée donc
leur nouveau députés sans donner pour
autant de majorité absolue à Emmanuel
Macron un an et une réforme des
retraites plus tard ou en est-on le
gouvernement parvient à faire passer une
bonne partie de ces textes avec ou 149-3
mais à quel prix est jusqu'à quand alors
qu'il reste beaucoup de textes alors du
jour avant les vacances on regarde le
menu parlementaire avec Elsa mon bagava
au programme des prochaines semaines le
partage de la valeur avec la
transposition de l'accord signé par la
quasi-totalité des partenaires sociaux
les dispositifs comme l'intéressement ou
la participation seront étendues aux
entreprises entre 11 et 49 salariés en
séance également le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice sur la période
2023 2027 près de 10000 postes seront
créés notamment des magistrats et des
greffiers le garde des sceaux promet de
diviser par deux les délais de justice
en 4 ans une mesure fait polémique
l'activation à distance des à l'insu de
leur propriétaire dans les affaires de
terrorisme ou de criminalité organisées
les parlementaires vont ensuite se
pencher sur l'industrie verte
réindustrialisation et décarbonation
avant la position estivale les députés
examineront le projet de loi pleine
emploi objectif 5% de chômage en 2027
Pôle Emploi deviendra France travail le
texte renforce les contreparties
demandées aux allocataires du RSA un
dispositif qui devrait susciter de vivre
débats dans l'hémicycle
Thomas ménager il reste des textes alors
du jour de l'assemblée est-ce que les
députés RN pourraient par exemple voter
le projet de loi sur le plein emploi qui
conditionne le versement du RSA à des
heures d'activité est-ce que ce serait
une bonne réforme alors vous la montrer
depuis le début on peut voter un certain
nombre de textes avec la majorité parce
que quand ils vont dans le bon sens
quand même ils sont insuffisants on peut
les soutenir sur celui-ci on est en
désaccord profonds déjà changé juste le
nom de Pôle emploi en France travail on
pense que ça va pas régler le problème
des Français et sur le RSA en tant que
tel on s'inquiète d'une menace notamment
une concurrence vis-à-vis de ceux qui
seront au SMIC de créer des sortes de
bullshit job si vous me permettez
l'expression de de Job pourri et de d'en
fait au final d'ubériser encore plus la
société c'est à dire de faire en sorte
que des employeurs se disent au final je
vais envoyer quelqu'un pour vous mais
c'est une réforme ultralibérale
c'est-à-dire que c'est vraiment dans la
continuité c'est-à-dire on va créer de
l'emploi mais on va pas créer des
emplois qui vont permettre aux gens de
vivre décemment mais on va créer des
emplois ubérisés et là indirectement
c'est une forme d'emploi alors bien
entendu il y a des peut-être des abus
sur
qu'il faut traiter mais ça ça va
beaucoup plus dans le bon sens et c'est
ce texte là lui pourrait avoir notre
soutien quand même des textes qui
peuvent recevoir votre soutien après la
réforme de retraites mais oui c'est pas
parce que le comportement c'est mal
comporté et passer en force tant par
l'utilisation 49-3 que par une
utilisation des tournées de l'initiative
et le blocage d'initiative parlementaire
avec l'article 40 que contre les
Français on va pas soutenir essayer
d'améliorer les textes qui vont dans le
bon sens est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement borne a un avenir à partir
de la mi-juillet c'est à dire à la fin
des 100 jours post-réforme de retraite
qui avait été dessiné par Emmanuel
Macron bah vraisemblablement le contrat
n'est pas rempli donc si on se dit le
contrat c'était de rétablir la confiance
avec les Français il suffit de sortir de
Paris sortir du Palais Bourbon ou du
Sénat pour se rendre compte que le
contrat n'est pas rempli les Français
n'ont pas du tout confiance dans ce
gouvernement en Isabelle borne donc si
tu arrives de décider moi je suis pas là
pour faire des pronostics mais elle a
pas rempli le contrat il lui reste plus
qu'un jour dans tous les cas pour le
faire est-ce que pour vous il y a un
avant et un après réforme des retraites
ce qui est certain c'est que il une
blessure qui s'est créée très profonde
qui existait un fossé entre la classe
politique et et les Français les
citoyens se fausser c'est creuser
surtout là maintenant vis-à-vis de la
majorité vis-à-vis de la macronie
vis-à-vis de renaissance et d'Elizabeth
borne et et on peut pas faire comme si
rien ne s'était passé après nous on a
une ligne de conduite qui est l'intérêt
général rien que ça dans nos positions
donc on va pas désormais passer dans une
opposition de principe quand bien même
le comportement a été indigne de la part
du gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron alors
cela fait un an que l'Assemblée
nationale a été élu avec une majorité
relative certains disaient qu'elle ne
tiendrait pas très longtemps au final
pour l'instant 68 textes ont été adoptés
ça veut dire que cette assemblée
fonctionne mais oui mais nous l'avons
toujours dit c'est comme quand on
propose parce que une proportionnelle la
proportionnelle à l'Assemblée nationale
on disait qu'il y aurait une instabilité
rien ne passerait bah là on a une
préfiguration ce que pourrait être la
proportionnel puisqu'en fait les
Français ont en partie permis de d'avoir
une Assemblée nationale qui est
représentative pas encore totalement
puisque on est à un peu en sous-effectif
par rapport à ce qu'on présente dans la
société et au final les textes passent
surtout parce que ça peut se faire car
nous nous avons une position pragmatique
et non sectaire après c'est vrai que
s'il y avait que LFI comme opposition
qui a voté 0% des textes et qui bloque
tout et qui ne veut absolument rien
passer quand bien même ça va dans le bon
sens ça ne pourrait pas avancer alors
vous dites groupe d'opposition mais
finalement Thomas ménager quand vous
écoute on a l'impression que vous êtes
vraiment très construit qui fait avec le
gouvernement et que vous êtes là aussi
pour l'aider à faire passer certains
textes mais on n'est pas là pour faire
passer les textes pour eux on est là
pour les Français donc oui c'est une
opposition constructive très ferme
attendez pendant la réforme des
retraites je pense qu'on a pas épargné
le gouvernement sur un certain nombre de
sujets on aura le texte sur
l'immigration je pense que il y aura des
débats qui vont être très vif le vous
parliez du débats qui aura sur le RSA on
peut avoir des positions très fermes
très frontales d'opposition mais ne pas
bloquer ce qui va permettre d'améliorer
ne serait-ce qu'un temps soit peu le
quotidien des Français finalement vous
êtes un petit peu comme le groupe LR
vous dites d'opposition mais vous faites
aussi passer certains textes non parce
que nous on va pas tripatouiller
négocier on va pas non plus
la macronie accuse de d'accointance
entre le RN et la gauche et vice versa
quand on vote avec la macronie peser sur
les textes nous dans tous les cas on
voit bien et puis au-delà de ça on pèse
aussi sur l'or du jour le texte
immigration le les dossiers que lancent
Gabriel Attal en matière de fraude on
voit qu'on a quand même du fait de notre
présence quand bien même sur certains
textes il refuse de nous écouter on a
une victoire des idées qui influence les
textes et la ligne actuelle du
gouvernement alors on va parler d'une
autre actualité puisque cette semaine
Gérald Darmanin décidé la dissolution du
mouvement les soulèvements de la terre
l'exécutif sur les accuses de cautionner
des violences à sainte-solines ou contre
le projet Lyon tout ira annonce faite à
l'Assemblée nationale mardi lors des
questions d'actualité
aucune cause monsieur le député ne
justifie que l'on blesse des policiers
ou des gendarmes
deux jours d'affrontement une autoroute
occupée une voie ferrée coupée et de
nombreux personnels des services publics
qui sont effectivement devant la haine
et la violence alors oui à la demande du
Président de la République et de la
première ministre demain matin je
présenterai au Conseil des ministres le
décret de dissolution les souleulément
de la terre
voilà et donc depuis le décret de
dissolution est effectif Thomas ménager
ce que cette dissolution est pour vous
justifier est-ce que les soulèvements de
la terre constituaient une menace réelle
pour l'ordre public oui je le pense il
suffit de voir le comportement vous avez
ils ont été cités le ministre de la cité
un certain nombre de comportements
encore récents avec l'agression du maire
de Toulouse il y a quelques jours il
faut aujourd'hui avoir une ligne très
claire vis-à-vis de tous les
groupuscules nous descendre 2022
Jean-Philippe Tanguy Marine Le Pen avait
écrit la première ministre pour demander
la distribution de tous les groupuscules
d'extrême gauche d'extrême droite quel
qu'il soit tous les groupuscules
violents on a déjà une société qui est
divisé une société qui s'ouvre et c'est
soulèvement de la terre aussi participe
à cette écho terroriste ça s'est
agribashing qui est très dangereux
notamment pour les lieux rurales que je
suis et je défends absolument nos
agriculteurs et surtout ils ont eu des
comportements indignes avec ceux qui
travaillent qui se lèvent tôt quand ils
ont été détruire notamment les
exploitations qui pourtant en plus
préparé l'avenir et préparer le progrès
pour protéger notre environnement alors
c'est la première fois qu'un mouvement
écologiste est dissout par l'État est-ce
que cette dissolution elle est aussi
politique c'est-à-dire la dissolution
d'un mouvement qui est opposé à la
politique du gouvernement notamment en
matière agricole non parce que n'importe
qui peut aujourd'hui s'exprimer et
exprimer son son rejet peut-être de la
politique du gouvernement en matière
environnementale mais ça se fait dans le
respect de l'État de droit dans le
respect de nos institutions ça se fait
pas avec violence mais c'est le premier
parce qu'on voit aujourd'hui qui est une
montée en puissance alimentée par les
élus de la République dont certains vont
avec fin de leur écharpe accompagné
soutenir ces personnes qui parfois ont
été ont été touchés par l'interdiction
de manifester c'est-à-dire c'est ça qui
inquiétant c'est que moi ce que je vois
plus largement c'est la préfiguration si
demain il y avait la France insoumise
notamment au pouvoir d'une société où il
y a plus d'états de droits où on ne
respecte plus aucune règle et c'est ça
surtout qui inquiétant ça vous choque
des élus de la République puisse se
trouver dans des manifestations même si
ils ont le droit même en cas de pour
insister à une manifestation
et pacifique autorisée oui si elle est
interdite non c'est pas la place d'un
élu de la République pour vous de non
mais dans une manifestation ça peut être
la place de la République bien entendu
même si il faut toujours et comme nous
l'avons fait pendant la retraite se dire
que le plus important c'est d'être là
pour travailler et faire le travail
parlementaire et quand tu as
manifestation est interdite non enfin un
moment il y a la loi si ceux qui
rédigent la loi vote la loi ne la
respecte pas mais où va-t-on vous parlez
de mouvement éco-terroriste pour les
soulèvements de la terre oui ah bah oui
je pense que c'est c'est une forme de de
terrorisme écologique toutes les actions
et les activistes aujourd'hui qui qui ne
respecte pas la loi qui vont attaquer
les exploitations attaquer des
infrastructures bien entendu c'est une
forme de terrorisme alors parce que les
avocats du soulèvement de la terre
disent que ce mouvement n'est pas en
lui-même violent ni dégrade des biens
alors est-ce que il ne fallait pas
plutôt condamner les les personnes qui
étaient responsables des violences
plutôt que de dissoudre le mouvement à
ma connaissance le sous moment de la
terre n'ont pas dénoncé les violences
non pas
exclus ces personnes donc ils ont même
pas fait preuve de cette volonté de
pacifier et de montrer que leur combat
était un combat noble la défense de
l'environnement et on peut même le
partager bien entendu mais aujourd'hui
ils ont toujours accompagné ces éléments
violents qui font partie et je pense que
c'est un axe de défense et c'est le rôle
de l'Avocat mais je pense que c'est très
loin de la réalité pourtant il y a pas
d'appel à la violence portée par les
soulèvements de la terre non mais lors
de l'ensemble des interventions du
soulèvement de la terre il y a des
violences de membres qui se revendiquent
des soulèvements de la terre donc
aujourd'hui vous savez le ministre il a
battu cette décision sur la base
d'intention voilà il y a des faits et
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on ne peut que
soutenir cette décision et notamment
pour protéger ceux qui bossent qui se
lèvent tôt nos agriculteurs qui ont été
attaqués par ces associations et
justement dans certaines manifestations
d'agriculteurs il y a parfois des
dégradations des policiers qui sont
blessés ce qu'il n'y a pas un deux poids
de mesure de la part du gouvernement non
mais dans toute manifestation il peut y
avoir des débordements mais là on voit
bien que c'est c'est organisé voulu et
que c'est répété et c'est à chaque fois
avec cette même association donc oui que
dans chaque manifestation que ce soit
des agriculteurs une manifestation
sociale avec des syndicats voilà mais à
chaque fois à aucun moment les les
syndicats agricoles ou les syndicats de
travailleurs non appelés à la violence
ou non non pas participé à dénoncer
cette violence mais Thomas ménager
est-ce que sur le fond vous comprenez
cette révolte contre l'inaction
climatique du gouvernement qui
d'ailleurs a été condamné sur ce point
mais je peux comprendre que les jeunes
s'inquiètent je peux comprendre qu'il y
ait des inquiétudes au vu des évolutions
climatiques des changements climatiques
et d'une il y a des faits qui peuvent
expliquer ces tensions mais aujourd'hui
ça se changera par les humains par par
des politiques publiques ça se changera
pas c'est pas parce qu'on va être
détruire
l'outil de travail d'une personne qu'on
arrivera à faire changer les choses moi
je ne crois pas que la violence permet
de faire changer permettre de changer
les choses dans notre pays moi je crois
à la démocratie je crois aux urnes et
donc je dis à ces jeunes engagez-vous
engagez-vous dans des partis politiques
venez nous accompagner tous à évoluer à
proposer des politiques publiques
ambitieuses en matière environnementale
mais le fait que avec respect et respect
notamment de ceux qui travaillent Thomas
Manager va continuer à parler d'écologie
puisque cette semaine le Sénat adopté le
projet de loi industrie vert tu as un
texte censé favoriser les filières
industrielles de la transition
écologique mais il n'est pas toujours
facile de concilier réindustriel
réindustrialisation et protection de
l'environnement les explications de
Flora sauvage pour développer batterie
électrique pompe à chaleur et panneaux
solaires il faut réindustrialiser la
France et décarboner l'économie c'est
l'objectif du projet de loi industrie
verte adopté par le Sénat en première
lecture l'exécutif veut faciliter la
réhabilitation et l'implantation de
nouvelles usines soumises à des
procédures trop complexes nous voulons
avec ce projet de loi réduire par deux
les délais d'ouverture ou
d'agrandissement de l'usine en France de
17 mois réel à 9 mois réels avec ce
texte le gouvernement crée un plan
d'épargne à venir climat destiné aux
jeunes les fond ce nouveau produit
d’épargne pourront être placés dès la
naissance et bloqué jusqu'à la majorité
le gouvernement espère ainsi mobiliser
un milliard d'euros de collecte pour
financer la transition écologique une
fausse bonne idée pour les sénateurs de
gauche qui proposent un ISF climatique
face à l'endettement de notre pays on ne
peut se priver de la taxation des plus
riches d'entre nous qui sont par
ailleurs je me permets de le souligner
ceux dont le mode de vie polluent le
plus de leur côté les sénateurs ont voté
une disposition permettant aux communes
d'acquérir des terrains qui ne sont plus
entretenus pour installer de nouvelles
usines 2/3 des intercommunalités déclare
déjà avoir refusé des projets
d'implantation économiques par manque de
foncier
pour réindustrialiser la France 16000 à
20000 hectares seront nécessaires
environ la moitié pourrait se faire en
recyclage de friches l'autre moitié en
artificialisation nouvelle pour lutter
contre la rareté des terrains
constructibles imposés par la loi zéro
artificialisation nette et sénateurs ont
choisi d'exclure les sites industriels
des quotas d'artificialisation des sols
un retour en arrière selon le
gouvernement le projet de loin industrie
verte devrait être au menu de
l'Assemblée nationale la deuxième
semaine de juillet
Thomas ménager première question très
directe est-ce que le groupe RN votera
ce texte industriel verte quand il
arrivera à l'Assemblée nous allons voir
les débats parce qu'il y a un certain
nombre de problématiques qui sont dans
ce dans ce texte notamment la question
ça a été dit du Zéro artificialisation
net on verra ce qui se lancera quand ça
arrivera à l'Assemblée nationale on a
déposé des amendements notamment pour
exclure les petites communes moi je suis
sur un territoire où il y a un taux de
chômage de plus de 10%, il y a une
contradiction aujourd'hui parce que moi
je vois des usines qui ferment des plans
sociaux qui continuent dans le Loiret
et en même temps cette volonté de
développer l'industrie bien entendu nous
depuis des années le rassemblement
national je pense étant point on n'a pas
attendu le covid on n'a pas attendu la
guerre en Ukraine pour se dire on a
besoin de gagner en indépendance
d'arrêter les importations qui sont
vecteurs bien entendu 50 % des gaz à
effet de serre sont liés aux
importations donc il y aura des
amendements pour est sur les petites
communes parce que il y a aussi souvent
une contradiction c'est à dire si on les
exclut au niveau du Zéro
artificialisation nette sur l'industrie
il va falloir le faire aussi pour
l'emploi parce que moi aujourd'hui j'ai
quelques usines qui s'implante notamment
à l'est de monter partement sur vers
Courtenay vers Château-Renard et où il
n'y a pas de logement c'est-à-dire que
si on ne peut pas loger les personnes
qui vont trouver du travail on aura une
contradiction donc il faut trouver de la
souplesse et donc nous allons voir ce
qu'il en sera valoir des débats pourtant
depuis 2017 les chiffres disent que 90
000 emplois industriels ont été créés
vous reconnaissez qu'Emmanuel Macron a
fait du bon travail pour faire revenir
des usines en France moi ce que je
constate c'est que il y a eu une
augmentation des investissements directs
à l'étranger mais qui crée quand même
beaucoup moins d'emplois que dans les
autres pays européens je vous constate
aussi que il y a eu des créations mais
qu'il y a eu aussi énormément de
suppression dans tous les cas tout ce
qui tout d'usine qui se crée tous les
projets qui peut y avoir actuellement en
cours dont on parle et gigafactory
l'arrivée d'usine comme Tesla dans tous
les cas on pourra être que favorable
puisque il y a des enjeux sociaux
économiques d'emploi il y a des enjeux
environnementaux c'est-à-dire d'éviter
le fret maritime des viétés et les
transports et d'éviter que ça soit fait
à l'autre bout du monde souvent dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas aussi
respectueuses de l'environnement et des
droits des travailleurs comme on peut
l'avoir en France que le patron de Tesla
choisit la France pour implanter sa
nouvelle usine et ce que finalement ça
n'aurait été peut-être pas possible il y
a 10 ans ça veut dire que des choses ont
été faites je pense qu'il y a eu un
changement de paradigme malheureusement
beaucoup trop tardivement de la part des
gouvernants successifs qui ont fait en
fait tout l'inverse pendant des années
donc là il y a un progressivement une
évolution je pense que le covid a permis
de faire évoluer les mentalités on
aurait aimé que ça soit le cas bien plus
tôt mais nous allons voir j'espère que
cette usine Elon Musk viendra investir
dans notre pays parce que c'est des
emplois à la clé et ça c'est une
nécessité aujourd'hui le point qui fait
débat également en ce moment c'est
l'objectif zan zéro artificialisation
des sols nets en 200050 comme la fixer
la loi sur le climat voté l'an dernier
est-ce que pour vous cet objectif est
viable est-ce qu'il faut la soupir ou
même peut-être le supprimer nous avons
déposé dans le cadre de ce texte des
amendements pour exclure les petites
communes puisque ce sont celles parfois
qui ont pas participé à leur
développement et maintenant se
retrouvent à être en difficulté cet
objectif il faut l'adapter c'est des
fermetures d'école moi je vois dans
certains secteurs on ne peut pas créer
de logement c'est la difficulté qu'on
aura à installer de nouvelles usines si
on se dit en France zéro
artificialisation nette mais que à
l'autre bout du monde on participe à de
la déforestation on participe à
construire souvent des conditions je
vous le disais à l'instant qui sont
beaucoup moins vertueuses que les nôtres
bien entendu il y a une contradiction
mais sur l'industrie il faut quand même
changer notre paradigme c'est à dire que
à un moment on nous dit on va
réindustrialiser c'est-à-dire qu'on va
relocaliser mais en même temps on a un
ministre qui montre en disant le
Mercosur quand bien même l'Assemblée
nationale vote une résolution pour dire
stop sur le Mercosur on va continuer
donc il y a quand même un changement de
paradigme qui n'est pas encore total sur
le sujet et pourtant par exemple sur les
voitures électriques Bruno Le Maire
annonce qu'il veut favoriser les
voitures produites en France en Europe
face au modèle chinois c'est une forme
de protectionnisme qui va dans le bon
sens mais oui les protectionnistes qu'on
appelle de nos vœux depuis des dizaines
d'années c'est à dire que je vais pas
vous dire le contraire parce que c'est
Bruno Le Maire j'attends de voir dans
les faits parce que on a souvent été
déçu de ceux qui est là encore c'est une
victoire idéologique sur la question de
l'industrie de la relocalisation de la
défense de nos emplois industriels on se
rend compte que on avait raison
peut-être avant beaucoup dans tous les
cas tant mieux si certains ouvrent les
yeux aujourd'hui et on les accompagnera
et on pourra que soutenir mais il faudra
regarder les conditions réelles petite
question très rapide sur le climat
Emmanuel Macron vente une ISF climatique
bonne idée ou pas pour vous nous
proposons après avoir supprimé l'ISF bon
nous allons donc voir concrètement ce
que qu'il entend par ISF climatique nous
ont proposons un impôt sur la fortune
financière c'est à dire de taxer la
spéculation mais ne pas taxer ce qui va
en finale créer de l'emploi en France
être injecté dans l'économie réelle donc
indirectement qui peut avoir un impact
écologique donc nous allons voir que les
dispositive sur sur le papier ça peut
valoir être intelligent de se dire
l'argent n'est plus riches peut aller à
à participer à au changement climatique
et à la transition écologique Thomas
ménager on se quitte avec un coup d'œil
à l'agenda du Parlement
[Musique]
lundi les députés entame en séance
publique l'examen du projet de loi sur
le partage de la valeur traduction
législative de l'accord conclu entre les
partenaires sociaux pour favoriser
l'intéressement et la participation
mardi les sénateurs commenceront
l'examen du projet de loi de
programmation militaire qui prévoit une
hausse budgétaire historique pour nos
armées 413 milliards d'euros de crédit
sur la période 2024-2030 et puis
mercredi la délégation au droit des
femmes du Sénat présentera son rapport
sur la santé des femmes au travail
Thomas manigion va finir par quelles
questions quelques questions justement
sur la loi de programmation militaire
vous l'avez voté à l'assemblée ça veut
dire que vous saluez la politique
militaire d'Emmanuel Macron on salue les
hausses de crédit que nous avons demandé
pendant la présidentielle c'est peu
ouprou exactement ce que nous avions
appelé nos vœux est-ce que Marine Le Pen
avait défendu donc oui après il va
falloir faire en sorte de maintenir
notre industrie militaire de veiller à
ce que nos munitions viennent notamment
d'Europe et de France il va y avoir un
certain nombre de points sur lequel on
aura des vigilances et puis après c'est
une loi de programmation va falloir voir
si chaque année ça sera converti
réellement dans les projets de loi de
finances en matière militaire est-ce que
vous souhaitez que la France reste dans
le commandement militaire intégré de
l'OTAN il y a l'Alliance atlantique et
le commandement militaire alors nous
souhaitons rester dans l'OTAN mais nous
ne souhaitons plus être dans le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN qui
oblige la France quand bien même
souverainement elle déciderait l'inverse
elle souhaiterait l'inverse de
participer à l'ensemble des
interventions internationales décidées
par l'OTAN nous nous souhaitons que le
peuple français vit assez représentants
parfois indirectement en suivant la
ligne des Américains qui bien entendu
ont une place prépondérante dans le dans
l'OTAN donc oui nous nous souhaitons
c'est une vision coliste d'indépendance
et d'être souverain pour intervenir en
coopération avec d'autres pays notamment
avec les Américains quand ils le font
mais de ne pas être lié automatiquement
il y a aussi dans les débats l'Assemblée
nationale sur cette votre programmation
militaire eu des discussions sur la
dissuasion nucléaire avec des
investissements supplémentaires
également la création d'un nouveau
porte-avions il faut aller dans cette
direction renforcer l'investissement
dans le la dissuasion nucléaire je vous
aurais répondu oui il y a 3 ans 4 ans
mais je vous réponds encore plus oui
aujourd'hui on voit malheureusement que
on rêverait tous d'un monde sans conflit
mais que nous avons un conflit à nos
portes en Ukraine que le monde n'est pas
aussi pacifique qu'on le souhaiterait et
que le rôle des dirigeants politiques
c'est d'éviter et de préparer la guerre
pour avoir la paix comme le dit l'adage
et donc bien entendu d'être équipé
d'avoir une force de dissuasion c'est
d'empêcher c'est d'éviter la guerre et
indirectement de s'y préparer si
malheureusement cela devait arriver
uniquement avec les armes est-ce que à
un moment donné il faudra pas que tout
le monde revienne à la table des
négociations nous c'est ce que nous
appelons de la rue c'est à dire que nous
avons eu une position pragmatique nous
avons soutenu notamment le président de
la République même Marine Le Pen dans la
présidentielle pour la présidentielle a
soutenu les initiatives de maintenir le
dialogue avec Vladimir Poutine tout en
étant très fermé en condamnant euh cette
guerre qu'il mène en Ukraine mais il
nous appelons de nos vœux une conférence
internationale de pour la paix c'est à
dire de réunir les grandes puissances
puissent permettre de réunir à la fois
les ukrainiens et Vladimir foodine
zenkins
diplomatie parce qu'il y a qu'une
issue ça sera dans ton caca la
diplomatie et la paix merci beaucoup
Thomas c'est la fin c'est la fin de
cette émission merci d'avoir été notre
invité à cette semaine et merci à tous
d'avoir suivi ce numéro de Parlement
Hebdo on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine ciao ciao
[Musique]